forever happens here that is the new
message from the lvcva to attract
couples to tie the knot in las vegas
christian costa is here live with a
closer look at this campaign and why one
couple decided to get hitched on the
strip
well brian talk about having a unique
experience right that's exactly what one
couple from michigan was looking for
they flew into town for their ceremony
avoided large gatherings due to covet
and even had elvis all shook up
[Music]
a special moment for ally and jarrett
who traveled to las vegas from michigan
to exchange vows
we obviously we knew we wanted to get
married so that was a big thing and for
us
with i think covet too specifically how
it's it's very different within the
realm of planning events and doing
things so i think something of just
being able to go and do it the couple
was searching for a unique experience
and one they would forever remember a
similar theme for the lvcba's newest
wedding campaign looking to attract more
couples to get hitched in the winning
capital of the world
charles byrne has officiated over four
thousand weddings and says this campaign
is on point the schtick is not what
people are looking for they're looking
for a meaningful ceremony as i say as
i'm sitting in an elvis juke the
campaign marks the exciting lead up to
las vegas issuing the 5th millionth
wedding license next year a celebration
that could be as lavish or intimate as
you like but with the vegas touch i now
pronounce you husband and wife i like to
do things untraditionally anyway so
i figured why not in vegas
alright the lvcva says vegas is the
perfect wedding destination because of
course why not right we have great hotel
deals amazing dining selection and of
course you can always extend your stay
christian casa is live local now